I know that flip-flops continuing how is
that
so we're filming season a we're about to
rap and it's gonna be tied up in about
this is the end of flip-flop I don't
know yet everything sort of up in the
air yeah we'll see how everything does
this summer and how much changed because
here's the thing I was a I'm a big fan
of that show and we all know that you
just did whatever you wanted it really
was slipper Christina said gets whatever
she wants yeah not so much anymore
no party's over
oh yeah
there's what much more like it's kind of
like on my show where the spouses have
different opinions sure and before I
kind of got my way more no no not so
much anymore more dark design really and
how's that I mean my house is gonna sell
we'll see I want to live in your house
chooses badly okay
well we'll see that'll be funny okay he
also actually really loved this well you
know that everyone has an opinion about
your life and the choices you make of
course um
and I loved you had this picture of you
and Tareq and you were like working
together and aunt hop someone was like
isn't that weird and he hopped on and
said no this is I'm so happy that
they're friendly and that's that must be
great for you yeah and he genuinely
feels that way which makes everyone's
lives so much easier I mean if only
everyone could be so happy per our
situation is it weird for you know uh-oh
he's busy honey he met me making date
back to the background of making that
furniture deal okay yes sure but it must
mean a lot to you because this is listen
this is a modern family but this is not
strange anymore this is the way our
generation is you know mixed families
and this kind of thing so it must make
you very proud of him and and both of
your guys yeah no it's awesome it's it's
exactly how it should be
it makes every like the goal is for the
kids to feel happy and settled and
that's what we want the same thing so
that really is how we live and how he
projects it
and that's just its personality and it's
trust me it's the best possible
situation for everybody did you have to
discuss this and be like alright I'll do
this with you you can come into my life
but here's the deal or do business nice
natural like who he was
that's just who he was because I had to
teach my husband how to be husband you
know I was like alright you come into my
life I'm never gonna be home yep he just
is naturally this person well luckily
and also because he is on TV and his
hours are longer than mine and he's been
in it so he's just used to it
but I really did find how well he
handled said to him there's gonna be
some criticism and negativity and I
swear he really just just rolls right
off it and he never cared there's no
judgment he just loves me for me I love
that
[Music]